هناك فيضانات والملايين من الاشخاص ينبغي
اجلائهم وتم البدء بعمليه الاجلاء هناك
اضرار هائله تم تسبب بها خاصه بالنسبه
فيما يتصل بالقطاع الزراعي اود ان اؤكد ان
قائد الجيش الاوكراني يرغب
بتدمير هذا السد للحصول على منافع عسكريه
وهدم
وهذا ما اشارت اليه 2022
جنرال الجيش الاوكراني كان يريد ان يتسبب
فيضان النهر وكان هناك عمليات استهداف
لهذا السد كخفقه وتم كسر ثلاثه
مواقع في السده لكي يروا يمكن لتدفق
المياه ان يؤثر على المواقع السوريه دون
الروسيه دون ان يؤثر سلبا على
القرى المجاوره وكان ذلك كحل يمكن اللجوء
اليه نهايه الاقتباس ونحن اكدنا ذلك
للاسره الدوليه
والمجلس الامن وارسلنا وثائق رسميه مذكره
من البعثه الدائمه فيما يتصل بمشاريع نظام
كييف لتدمير هذه المحطه وناسف لان
نداءاتنا للامين العام للامم المتحده
للقيام
هذه الكارثه وانه لم يتم التوقف عند هذه
المستندات واخذها على محمل
الجد
وكان تم تشجيع لكياف من الغرب وذلك
لارتكاب هذه
الاعمال الارهابيه من الصعب ان نقنع اي
طرف
بان هذا النزاع في اوكرانيا هو بسبب عمل
روسيا
الجانب الغربي يرفض
الاعتراف بانه تم الاستعداد لهذا الانقلاب
في ميدان والمناهض للدستور وهذا الامر
بالاضافه الى تدابير متخذه ضد الناطقين
باللغه الروسيه في الشرق
ودون الاقتراف بحياه المليم من الاشخاص
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الروسيه وضعت حدا
لهذه الاعمال وهناك بعض المعلومات المنسقه
او حمله للمعلومات المغلوطه واعلانات طنان
من الغرب ومن كاف بشان هذا الموضوع
وسنستمع الى هذه
التصريحات اليوم وتقول ان هذا السد تم
تخريبه من قبل روسيا
هذه الاقوال تذهب في الاتجاه نفسه هي
[موسيقى]
وهي تشهد وهنا وهذا بالاضافه الى عسكره
الجانب الشرقي
لشني
الهجمات الهدف الثاني من هذا هذه الهجمه
هو
الحاق الضرر بسكان هذه المنطقه وتدمير هذه
البنى التحتيه الهائله سيفضي الى اضرار
واسعه النطاق وان السلطات خير
تقوم باجلاء المواطنين في المناطق التي
يمكن ان تصبح مغموره هذا التخريب افضل الى
كارثه ايكولوجيه
ومئات المناطق الماهوله مغموره على بقرب
اي كيف تحاول
ان تحرم
سكان جزيره القرم من هذه من المياه هو
في الوقت نفسه سلطاتك
تستمر في
زياده منسوب المياه في خلال عبر السد
وعمليه التخريب اذا كانت مقصوده ولتواصل
النتائج وخيمه لكل سكان المنطقه جرائم
نظام كيف
واستمرار الغرب بتوفير الاسلحه لها هذا
يعني ان ينبغي بكيف والغرب ان يتحمل
مسؤوليات هذه الكارثه وهذه النتيجه
التكتيك من بدات في 2014 لاستهداف البنى
التحتيه المدنيه وذلك لتوصل الى اضرار
كبيره للمدنيين وهذا الامر محظور بشكل
واضح من قبل الماده والخمسين
ارهابيه من النظام الرسمي وهو يفتخر بهذه
التدابير دارياد وعمليات
الاغتيالات الاخرى
وسمعنا رغبات في استهداف الروس ولكن
العواصم الغربيه لم تدل ذلك ونظام كياف
يمكن ان
نذكركم
والغرب
معتاد على
توكيل الغير بتنفيذ هذه المهام الفظيعه
نحن نفهم من يقوم بتخطيط هذه الامور من
يقوم بالاستعدادات ومن يدعم
عمليه التخريب على نطاق واسع لا نفهم كيف
يمكن للامانه العملي والمتحده ان ترفض
ادانه نظام كييف وتقول انما من معلومات
كافيه مثلا يمكن ان تتذكر ما حدث مع محطه
نوويه نحن نعلم ما كان مصدر عمليات
الاطلاق القذائف
وهناك عدد من المداخلات السياسيه التي
تقول انها نتيجه الاعمال الروسيه في
اوكرانيا هناك انكار ورفض
لا يمكن ان نفهمه الاحترام الحياديه من
قبل الامانه وذلك وفقا للماده 100 من
الميثاق ان وجدعوه للامانه لكي تتوصل
استنتاجات
موضوعيه وادانه تدابير كييف نشدد على هذا
الموضوع علينا نلقي ضوء على ظروف هذا
العمل الهمجي ضد كخفقه علينا ان
نتفادى تكرار شكرا
لممثل الاتحاد الروسي الموقر على هذه
المداخله المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات